[موسيقى]
اخبار الانتخابات التركيه بايجاز من
اسطنبول مرحبا بكم تركيا تدخل مرحله الصمت
الانتخابي عشيه يوم الاقتراع في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والتشويعيه وخلال هذه
الفتره يحضرون اي اخبار او تعليقات تتضمن
دعايه انتخابيه كما يمنع تداول كل ما من
شانه ان يؤثر على الحريه التامه للناخبيه
المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات يعلن ان الاصوات
الممنوحه للمرشح المنسحب محرم انجي ستعتبر
ساريه في الجوله الاولى ورئيس المجلس يقول
ان انسحاب انجي بعد اعلان قائمه المرشحين
في الجريده الرسميه لن يكون ساريا ردا على
تصريح المرشح الرئاسي كمال كليش دار اوغلو
بان الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان لم يتقدم بطلب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لاعاده رئيس
تنظيم الكيان الموازي فتح الله وزاره
العدل تعلنوا انها تقدمت بسبع طلبات
لاعادته لوقوفه خلف المحاوله الانقلابيه
عام 2016 وتهمه اخرى
المرشح الرئاسي عن تحالف اتا الاجداد سنان
اوغان يقر بعدم امكانيه وصوله الى الجوله
الثانيه في الانتخابات ويقول ان بامكانه
ان يحدد نتيجتها لكنه نفى الانضمام اليه
تحالفات بدون مقابل مشيرا الى طلبات تتمثل
في منصب نائب الرئيس وعدد من الوزراء الى
اللقاء